avec nous François Jolivet bonsoir alors
vous êtes le président du codative le
Comité Départemental d'animation et de
théâtre amateurs des Yvelines et vous
allez présenter un événement qui se
déroulera du 11 juin jusqu'au 25 juin
c'est le théâtre à la ferme le théâtre
dans les fermes pourquoi amener le
théâtre dans les fermes tout est dit au
niveau de notre slogan quand les
planches
rencontrent les champs je pense que
l'idée c'est de marquer deux choses
différentes qui sont le théâtre et puis
les nourritures terrestres et puis de
faire venir du nouveau public dans des
lieux magnifiques ce qu'on peut à la
fois
c'est pour le plaisir des yeux parce
qu'il y a des très très jolis lieux et
puis
le plaisir aussi des papis puisque on
pourra déguster un certain nombre de
produits dans les fermes donc on aura
quatre événements on commence dimanche
au bureau avec la ferme de La Haye il y
a une journée portes ouvertes ensuite le
18 nous serons à la Faisanderie à
Villepreux dans un lieu magnifique on
aura si un autre Bergerac
au bord du Gally ensuite le 21 nous
serons à la ferme de bulloyer à
Magny-les-Hameaux à la suite du marché
mercredi après-midi et on terminera par
les Fables de La Fontaine à la ferme des
Mousseaux un joueur pontchartra voilà ce
qui est important aussi c'est qu'à
chaque fois derrière ces fermes il y a
des familles des familles qui sont
appuies longtemps et qui nous ouvre
leurs portes et pour nous c'est
formidable parce que ça permet de à la
fois de mettre en valeur le lieu et puis
et puis de montrer que c'est accessible
à tous le théâtre et qu'on passe un bon
moment voilà et alors pourquoi ces
pièces c'est un eau de Bergerac les
Fables de La Fontaine pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez choisi ces pièces là alors
tout simplement nous faisons appelé un
candidature auprès de nos 52 adhérents
52 troupes adhérentes et puis on essaie
de choisir au mieux d'avoir une
cohérence entre le lieu
et puis la pièce que je choisis voilà et
puis sur certains lieux on a choisi des
pièces plus courtes
avec également les les agriculteurs ou
les propriétaires et
pour ce qui est de la ferme notamment
faire de la Faisanderie c'est quand même
propriété de la famille develette
Develay a été directrice adjointe
président du hand-lagh qui a durable à
Paris donc on a souhaité trouver en
accord avec la famille une pièce qui me
paraissait voilà à la hauteur à la fois
du lieu et pour lui rendre également
honneur voilà donc pour d'autres on a
d'autres pièces plus courtes on utilise
toute la richesse des troupes
yvelinoises
êtes amener dans les fermes parce que
c'est quand même quelque chose d'un peu
insolite parce qu'à la fois un peu
insolite alors bon savoir si l'idée
d'avoir deux sujets de sujets c'est plus
c'est plus porteur mais semble-t-il ou
de thèmes à titre plus personnel
excusez-moi de cette validité ayant
quelques aïeux agriculteurs et Linois je
voilà j'ai proposé cette idée voilà mais
je pense que c'est intéressant d'aller
vers de nouveaux publics en provisant de
nouvelles approches comme vous avez fait
tout à l'heure et c'est très intéressant
de voir cela parce que ça permet d'avoir
une autre approche qui est dans un
moment qui se veut à la fois convivial
et sympathique et on a quatre lieux
extrêmement différents et ça c'est très
très intéressant et des troupes très
motivés qui font qui font venir jouer
alors l'entrée libre il y a un chapeau
nous en mettons donc je dirais
puisque la seconde édition par la
Communauté de l'agglomération de 51
Yvelines qui nous a octroyé une petite
latine entière qui est la bienvenue pour
organiser ce type de manifestation voilà
donc on est très heureux de le faire et
très heureux de faire découvrir de
beaulieues dans et puis aussi de bons
produits alimentaires voilà
est-ce que le but c'est pas ça justement
aussi c'est de faire découvrir au
spectateur qu'on peut être plus
l'habitude des salles de théâtre là de
les faire venir dans les fermes
yvelinoises leur faire découvrir un peu
le territoire aussi c'est tout à fait
découvrir le territoire et d'essayer
d'aller on essaie d'être un peu dans des
endroits différents donc on est au
bureau dans un lieu qui est très très
très classique en termes de production
agricole et les lieux un peu plus
prestigieux donc on essaye d'aller un
peu partout
après peut-être que les prochains on ira
dans une autre fait dans plus de ferme
enfin voilà mais si je pense une idée
c'est de à la fois découvrir les lieux
et découvrir la production qu'on y
trouve et de faire profiter je dirais au
public qu'on espère le plus nombreux
possible
par rapport à votre première édition
qui vous attendez plus de personnes on
espère avoir plus de plus de personnes
possible bien évidemment
les gagnants on avait que deux fermes
c'est la première édition là on est
passé à 4 fermes et donc on espère les
fermiers les agriculteurs parce qu'ils
ont souvent des événements et ça permet
de se prendre c'est une ferme la failli
Fano martinfano
le théâtre fin fait sur labyrinthe dans
le maïs pour ce qui est de des Mureaux
la famille frema fait une journée portes
ouvertes le dimanche et donc on est on
est dans ce dans ce cadre là pour ce qui
est le plus loyer Bruno et Marc et son
équipe et tous les mercredis avec les
jeunes il y a un marché donc on va
se faire connaître aussi on est dans une
démarche comment on dit en management
gagnante mais je pense que c'est
vraiment deux énergies qui se fédèrent
au service du public des lieux et et je
dirais de la cause agricole voilà
et puis pour ce qui est de la
Faisanderie parce qu'un lieu extrêmement
somptueux voilà et j'invite le plus de
publications malgré les petits soucis
qu'il y a sur la route départementale
merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions alors si
vous êtes intéressés vous retrouverez
les quatre dates et les quatre lieux sur
le site internet
codatives.fr qui s'affiche sur votre
écran